okay there was another debate last night
I'm sure you heard about it I and we've
got how many more of these things to go
we've got like a year and a half worth
of debates oh my lord
I can't uh god save me god save me
please just deliver me from this Lord I
can't I just can't do it
I'm not crying well I'm crying a little
bit I just can't imagine how I mean hey
how does this happen
how's this happening already did I feel
like the camp the campaigning never
stopped I feel like we never left an
election year we've been in an election
year my entire life and I just can't
take it anymore you know I was I was I'm
a football fan so I like to watch
football during the season and and I
also like to watch during the season the
analyst shows of what are the guys all
sit around and girls - okay not
discriminating like to sit around on TV
and they talk about the games that
happened over the weekend and they
predict what's going to happen in the
upcoming games and I like to watch those
those those shows those football talk
shows but it never fails to occur to me
as I'm watching it how kind of stupid
and pointless it really is that you've
got all these people sitting around
talking about a game and very seriously
analyzing it and discussing you know
which which team do they think is gonna
do better in the game next week than the
other but yet how I enjoyed watching it
anyway but really I think talking and
analyzing and I thought this last night
as I was flipping through cable news
after the debate watching all the
Talking Heads analyzing the debate and I
realized that's even more stupid and
pointless actually because the debates
are a game also but at least with
football you know it's a game and nobody
hides and also football is a lot less
scripted it's a lot less predetermined
than is a debate but we all sit around
the you know these canned lines these
pre-planned prepackaged scripted lines
that these politicians had already that
they already decided they were gonna fit
in and and so they give their little
line and then we all discuss the loads
it was a great it was a great moment
from her when she well what a great
moment when she said the line that her
staffer gave to her to say anyway I
yes on my part it's not very good a
professional for me to complain about
the thing that I'm going to spend much
of the show talking about
so forget everything I just said let's
start over there was another debate last
night and boy was it exciting and
relevant to your life and that's why I'm
going to talk about it today now not to
spoil anything but the major takeaways
seemed to be Joe Biden his old Bernie
wants to get people free stuff nobody
has any idea how they're going to enact
any of the policies they proposed Kamala
Harris is not accusing Biden of racism
but she's definitely accusing him of
racism and marianne williamson whoever
that is needs to lay off the Buddhism oh
and Andrew yang was the only guy on the
stage with with with somewhat
interesting ideas I didn't say good
ideas interesting ideas which means
naturally he was given about 14 seconds
to speak we're gonna go through talk
about some of the stuff in more depth
really the headline for me is it just
like the night before Wednesday night
the Democrats on the stage took off the
mask and let their extremism shine
through especially on immigration and
we'll get to that in a moment
but for the media and the pundits that's
not going to be the headline and you see
how it really doesn't matter what
happens in the debate what matters is
the narrative the media creates after
the facts so the media narrative which
was already predetermined was that
Kamala Harris was electrifying and
wonderful and she's now a rising star
the media is a self-fulfilling prophecy
that prophecy they they want her to be
as a rising star they'd already decided
before the debate that she was going to
be the rising star after the debate and
so now she's going to be a rising star
because they said so just like the media
decided that for 400 a little while for
a few weeks it felt like O'Rourke was
the rising star and then they got bored
of him and they said never mind and he's
not a rising star anymore so Harris had
basically two moments one was a candle
line that a staffer obviously gave her
to use a bad line actually and I'll
explain why in a second then the other
was a shameful attempt yet a successful
attempt to smear Joe Biden Wilde
attending that she was not smearing him
nothing particularly amazing or
brilliant about any of it it was it was
competent but but which is more than I
can say for some of the people on the
stage but nothing amazing about it yet
we're told it was amazing a brilliant so
let's look first at the canned line she
used that everybody is fawning over
watch this guys you know what America
does not want to witness a food fight
they want to know how we're gonna put
food on their table okay now again
that's a line that someone gave her and
she waited for a chance to unit use it
fine but it's actually wrong okay two
sentences in both sentences are wrong
first of all she says that note that
people aren't there to witness a food
fight yes they definitely are that's
exactly why people are tuning in it's
always funny when politicians say this
at the base they say folks okay you know
people aren't watching this to see us
fight okay yes we are that's all that's
the only reason we're watching it so yes
please fight that's the whole reason but
more to the point she says that we want
to know well we don't want to see a food
fight we want to know how are they gonna
put food on our table they being the
politicians again know is the answer to
that I don't want to know that I I'm not
watching a debate to find out how food
is how are you gonna put food on my
table there's like my kids come in hey
Dad what's for dinner tomorrow I don't
know I'll watch the debate tonight I'll
let you know what Camilla Harris has to
say okay I gotta check with her first
maybe she's gonna make us lasagna but
I'm not sure yet don't get your hopes up
um no that's that what a gross and
patronizing and stupid line that
everybody who applause oh my god she
what a life do you notice how she said
food and then she used food again she
used food in two different context that
was a mate while well Wow guys oh that
was really smart that was great what a
great line what a moment what a moment
of that line was no it was a moment of
utter stupidity what that's what you
want you want politicians to put food on
your table you pathetic and
andt alized baby not you specifically
we're watching this I'm sure you're not
that I'm just yelling at the
hypothetical person who thinks that's a
good line that that so that's nanny
state of statism in the extreme it's a
infantilizing and insulting and it's
just it's just not true but of course it
got huge applause because because she's
half right some folks actually do want
to know how politicians are gonna put
food on their table there are some
people in this country who are like baby
birds basically with their chirping with
their eyes closed and their mouths open
just waiting for a bureaucracy to
regurgitate pre-chewed food into their
mouths there are people in this country
that are like that unfortunately quite a
lot of people and the Democratic Party
is trying to breed more of them but it
is just disgusting and wrong and so that
was a bad line so that was that was
Camille Harris Bernie Sanders there were
a couple of interesting moments with
Bernie Sanders and we'll talk about
those in just a minute but first you
know it's it's summertime and the only
thing more annoying than having to watch
57 Democrat debates while the life is
slowly sucked out of you our flies and
other insects invading your home and who
knows you know where those flies have
been fly landing on your salad salad or
on your on your sandwich could have been
on the dirty diaper before okay could
have been in a garbage heap could have
been on a dead squirrel okay I mean
they're I could keep listening things
that it could have been on because flies
are gross so you don't want that that's
why we'd like to thank our sponsors over
at dynatrap dynatrap is the leading
manufacturer of outdoor mosquito and
insect traps and now they've come up
with in a solution for indoor pests the
dynatrap fly light the dime trap fly
light works day and night to attract and
trap flies fruit flies mosquitoes other
pests pesky insects and I'll tell you it
works for me we've got these things
we've got a bunch of them all over the
house now and they are because kids are
always leaving the door open that's one
thing kids are incapable of doing is
shutting a door behind them so they
leave the door open flies come in but
these things really take care of the
Flies in fact I was walking I had we
have one up here and I was walking by
one there was a there was a beetle
trapped in there
and the beetle was trying to escape but
I just sat and watched the beetle trying
to get out and I said she'll never
escape beetle and I rub my hands
together very nefariously
but that's kind of weird you don't have
to do that but the point is that
dinotrap takes care of the problems if
you want to get a dynatrap fly light you
can get yours at dynatrap calm that's dy
and ATR AP calm and to the promo code
walsh or c 15% off any of their products
dynatrap is the safe silent and simple
solution to household insect control
once again dynatrap comm go there and
get yours now all right Bernie Sanders
interesting moments with him speaking of
nanny state ISM and baby birds chirping
for food to be regurgitate it into their
mouths Bernie Sanders wants very much to
be the mama bird for all of us spitting
food into our mouths
which is a horrifying mental image that
you now have in your head thanks to me
there were a couple interesting moments
with him the first was when he finally
admitted that he wants to take money
from the middle class now he always
pretends that all the money's going to
come from the millionaires and
billionaires but here you finally I want
you to watch this whole exchange because
he finally admits it watch this right
here will taxes go up for the middle
class in a Sanders administration and if
so how do you sell that to voters well
you're quite white we have a news ition
for America and at a time when we have
three people in this country owning more
wealth than the bottom half of America
while 500,000 people are sleeping out on
the streets today we think it is time
for change real change and by that I
mean that health care in my view is a
human right and we have got a past amen
care for all single-payer system under
that system by the way that's majority
of the people in this country will be
paying significantly less for health
care than they are right now I believe
that education is the future for this
country and that is why I believe that
we must make public colleges and
universities tuition-free and eliminate
student debt and we do that by placing a
tax on Wall Street every proposal that I
have brought forth is fully paid for
standards I'll give you ten seconds just
to ask the answer the very direct
question will you raise taxes for the
middle class in a Sanders administration
people who have health care on the
Medicare for all will have no premiums
no deductibles no co-payment snow out of
expand out of pocket expenses yes they
will pay more in taxes but less in
health care for what they get all right
he comes out with it once and for all
which is good because Bernie really
hates to go into specifics and you've
got to trap him to get him to do it and
so he finally says oh yeah well I'm
gonna help the middle class by taking
money from the middle class that's
basically his plan and but speaking of
his plan there was there was a there was
another moment or again remember he
likes to scream about millionaires and
billionaires that's this whole thing and
drug companies right those are those are
the bad guys but there was there was
there was one part of the debate where
the moderators actually did a good job
and they tried a couple of times saying
hey Bernie okay you want to give health
care to everybody free stuff never how
are you going to do it very specific
question very reasonable question not a
gotcha not a trap question how are you
going to do it and this was his non
answer watch
[Applause]
the private health insurance system as
we know it and replace it with a
government-run plan none of the states
that have tried something like that
California Vermont New York has
struggled with it have been successful
if politicians can't make it work in
those states how would you implement it
on a national level how's this work
listen I find it hard to believe that
every other major country on Earth
including my neighbor 50 miles north of
me Canada somehow has figured out a way
to provide health care to every man
woman and child and in most cases
they're spending 50% per capita what we
are spending let's be clear let us be
very clear the function of health care
today from the insurance and drug
company perspective is not to provide
quality care to all in a cost-effective
way the function of the health care
system today is to make billions in
profits for the insurance companies and
last year if you could believe it while
we pay the highest prices in the world
for prescription drugs and I will
lowered prescription drug prices in half
in this country top ten companies make
sixty nine billion dollars in profit
they will spend hundreds of millions of
dollars lying to the American people
telling us why we cannot senator a
Medicare I just have to follow up there
how do you implement it out of national
[Applause]
it's not succeeded in other states
abstract I will tell you how we'll do it
we'll do it the way real change has
always taken place whether it was the
labor movement the civil rights movement
or the women's movement we will have
Medicare for all when tens of billions
of people are prepared to stand up and
tell the insurance companies and the
drug companies that their day is gone
that health care is a human right not
something to make huge profit
senator Sanders how are you going to
give health care to all well I'll tell
you how we're gonna give health care to
all okay but how by giving health care
to all yeah but how though well health
care at all that's how we're gonna do it
well if that was uncomfortable which it
was it was nothing compared to this
which is the moment that people are
raving about of Harris calling Biden a
racist but not calling him a racist
watch growing up my sister and I had to
deal with the neighbor who told us her
parents couldn't play with us because
she because we were black and I will say
also that that in this campaign we have
also heard and I'm gonna now direct this
at Vice President Biden I do not believe
you are a racist and I agree with you
when you commit yourself to the
importance of finding common ground but
I also believe and it is personal and I
was actually very it was hurtful to hear
you talk about the reputations of two
United States senators who built their
reputations and career on the
segregation of race in this country and
it was not only that but you also worked
with them to oppose busing and you know
there was a little girl in California
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools and she was
bused to school every day and that
little girl was me so I will tell you
that on this subject
it cannot be an intellectual debate
among Democrats that's really and I'm
not a Joe Biden fan but I that's one of
the dirtiest things I've ever seen or at
least that I've seen in a while at a
debate it's certainly in the top ten and
you knew it was gonna be bad as soon as
she said
Vice President Biden I don't think
you're a racist but see the but when you
attach a butts a very magical but that
you're attaching when you attach a butt
to a statement like I don't think you're
racist
or I'm not a racist it's just any time
there's a but after the word racist then
you what happened is what's going on is
that everything before that but has been
erased
so it's forget about what was said
before the but now it's just let's move
on to the statement and she moves on to
accusing Biden of racism basically even
though she knows that Biden is not a
racist she knows it I mean it's there
are a lot of things you could say about
Biden many of them not good but one but
one thing you cannot honestly say about
him is that he's a racist and they all
know that and at any rate if they really
do think the guy as a segregationist
bigoted Klansmen basically then they're
to blame for saying nothing about it for
40 years Harris never it Harris has been
in the game for a while now she never
said anything about it during the Obama
administration she never she never said
hey by the way Barack Obama you chose a
racist segregationist who opposed busing
and
you know who caused me all this pain as
a young girl that's a an emotional story
an emotional moment that I'm sure she
rehearsed plenty of times beforehand but
it's an emotional moment oh yeah where
was that emotional moment for the eight
years that he was a vice president if
you really think that he's got some he's
either a segregationist himself or he's
got some warm feelings about segregation
or whatever then why didn't you say
anything so I we have two options here
now for Harris
either she's just a lying fraud or she's
a coward who allowed a segregationist
racist bigot to be in the White House
all those years and said no in her own
party and said nothing so those are the
options but maybe Biden is learning
something at the age of 76 which is that
in the Democrat Party in the modern
Democrat Party anyway you're racist if
you're a white man especially an old one
and it's as simple as that you're not
going to get away from it you're gonna
be accused of racism they're kind of
accusing mayor Pete of racism a little
bit they're throwing a race thing at him
they're not doing it with swal well but
only because he's
holding at negative 32% so it doesn't
matter once you as a white man if you if
you peek your head above the fray a
little bit you're gonna get cut down
with racism claims that's the way that
it works now in the modern Democratic
Party all right a couple other things
here's the moments when the Democrats
when the Democrats really let their
extremist flag fly which they did two
nights ago and they did it again last
night a lot of you have been talking
tonight about these government health
care plans that you proposed in one form
or another this is a show of hands
question and hold them up for a moment
so people can see
raise your hand if covered if your
government plan would provide coverage
for undocumented immigrants I am old
enough to remember I'm old enough to
remember up until you know the last 55
seconds or so when Democrats always
pretended that they weren't giving
health care to illegals that they didn't
want to get free health care in fact
they not only they don't they not only
denied that claim but they said that
claim is absurd ridiculous a lie we
would never do it and now all of them
are just raising it you want to give
free health care to everybody in the
world anyone who happens across the
border oh yeah sure me do yeah and then
of course it's an applause line from the
trained seals in the audience good by
the way those are the people that in any
debate the people that I hate the most
are they are the audience they always in
know hate is a strong word they are the
ones who I am the most annoyed by always
are the audience members who just will
clap at anything without even thinking
about it so now we're clapping at giving
healthcare to well okay so you just yeah
yeah give free health care to anyone in
the world and no matter who they are
sure well let's get free health care to
7 billion people oh yeah why not I mean
I can't I can't think of any reason why
that wouldn't work except for maybe
about 7 billion reasons it's just it's
it's total madness and it's also it's
not just stupid and mad and and
impractical and all those things it is
those things but it's also morally Obama
it's its it is it is a moral atrocity
what you just witnessed cloaked in
compassion of course cloaked in this
claim of that they want to help people
they would help sick people what they're
doing is they are enticing more people
to come across the border they are
enticing more people to cross the Rio
Grande just like that father and
daughter didn't drowned in the process
they are enticing more people to make
that dangerous potentially fatal
hazardous trek across deserts across
rivers across places where there are
drug cartels and bandits and wild
animals they are enticing people to do
that by saying yeah come here and we'll
take care all your medical bills it is
it is that's not the kind of thing you
say if you actually care about these
people all right
finally let's lighten the mood a bit a
woman named Mary Ann will Williamson was
also there I'm not sure why but she was
there and her contributions were like
well you know how you have that one aunt
who comes to Thanksgiving and derails
every conversation with irrelevant
personal stories and all you can do
while she babbles a smile politely and
wait for her to start toss stop talking
so that you can continue the
conversation where you left off before
she interjected you know that that we
all have that that aunt that that person
at the Thanksgiving table Williamson not
only behaved like that aunt but she even
kinds of kind of looks like that on she
looks like every person's eccentric aunt
so there were a couple moments with her
here's my favorite probably my favorite
Williamson moment right here
who said that her goal is to make New
Zealand the place where it's the best
place in the world for a child to grow
up and I would tell the girlfriend you
were so on because the United States of
America is going to be the best place in
the world for a child to grow up thank
you you guys were close with the short
at least it was shorter would you say it
was hard for me to understand but she
said girlfriend you are so on which I am
gonna start using that phrase a lot more
than I have in the past because I never
had before but girlfriend you are so on
that's a
but she now if so she's claiming that
she had a conversation with a New
Zealand Prime Minister I guess and the
prime minister of New Zealand said I'm
gonna make a New Zealand the best place
for a young girl to grow up and
Williamson said girlfriend you were so
on because I'm gonna make America when
I'm president I'm gonna make America the
best place to grow up if that
conversation actually happened which it
probably didn't but if it did I could
only imagine the prime minister of New
Zealand what her facial expression must
have been when marianne williamson is
claiming that she's gonna be president
and she's gonna change the country you
know that New Zealand Prime Minister was
probably like yeah sure mm-hmm
yeah I know you are I know you are
Marian yeah that's gonna be great when
you're president mm-hmm okay and then
here was her her closing statement I'm
sorry we haven't talked more tonight
about how we're going to beat Donald
Trump I have an idea about Donald Trump
Donald Trump is not going to be beaten
just by insider politics talk he's not
going to be beaten just by somebody who
has plans he's going to be beaten by
somebody who has an idea what this man
has done this man has reached into the
psyche of the American people and he is
harnessed fear for political purposes so
mr. president if you're listening I want
you to hear me please you have harnessed
fear for political purposes and only
love can cast that out so I sir I have a
feeling you know what you're doing I'm
going to harness love for political
purposes I will meet you on that field
and sir love will win we got a harness
the power of love she marianne
williamson basically speaks like 80's
pop lyrics she speaks in 80 songs is I
think that's that's I would that's how I
would nail it down for her but it was
good to have her and have her there and
kind of breaking up the monotony a
little bit
and honestly I I hope that she is the
nominee I think that that would be a lot
of fun okay before we go any further I
need to tell you about freedom project
Academy this year nearly seventy billion
dollars with a be of taxpayer money will
be spent on public education yet a new
report fine
that just two and five American students
are actually ready to attend college so
the the public education the money we're
spending it's not doing the job public
education is not doing the job and we
could see that all around just look
anywhere and you can see just walk
outside of your house have have
interactions with human beings in this
country and you could tell that ok
public education is not working many of
you then have been searching for school
with traditional values that help
students develop strong foundations in
math science English American history
the kind of education where students are
taught how to think not just what the
thing not not taught you know what
things to pair it what concepts and
phrases to repeat but how to work
through problems your search is over
freedom project Academy is an accredited
online school built on judeo-christian
values in classical curriculum for
students from K all the way through high
school talking about a complete
interactive educational experience where
students attend live classes with other
students from across the country Freedom
Project Academy provides live and
recorded lessons homework tests tutoring
grades transcripts so it's all there
this is the answer to your prayers go to
freedom freedom for school comm freedom
for school comm and request your free
information packet today that's freedom
for school comm enrollment ends July
19th so don't wait long you don't have a
lot of time get on that now don't forget
to subscribe to their weekly education
podcast the dr. Duke show available
available a lot of iTunes and everywhere
else again enrollment ends on July 19th
so get on it take back control of your
kids education freedom for school comm
freedom for school comm freedom for
school comm alright there's there's an
article in Cosmo that's gone viral
online and it's a Cosmo article so of
course it's stupid and gross and just
bad in every way but I actually think
that there's something we can learn from
this one the title is I've cheated on
every boyfriend I've ever had and I
don't regret it now the writer who
bravely remains anonymous goes into
elaborate details about the many times
that she's cheated
I'm not going to read all the details
you can just imagine what it's like what
this article is like all but I will read
let me read a few steps
snippets just so you get an idea she
says cheating is one of the big no knows
they flashing do not pass sign one of
the few things most people in the world
can agree is very bad it's a capital s
scandal something you have to have
literally Beyonce level strength to
forgive and I would know I saw one of my
parents do it to the other and now
because of that they are no longer
married still knowing this I've cheated
on all three of my serious boyfriends
I'm not completely morally bankrupt yes
you are and I feel bad for lying even if
the lie only live for a few days or
weeks until I broke up with each guy but
I don't regret each instance of cheating
not really because although they were
all very different each experience
taught me crucial things about myself
and my sexuality in my early 20s before
I go any on go for go further just
imagine how she says she's not morally
bankrupt but of course imagine how
morally bankrupt you have to be to cheat
when you're just dating someone now
cheating when you're married is more
serious and worse
but there's one uniquely awful element
of cheating in a non marriage
relationship and that is that you can
leave the relationship easily like if
you're if you really are not into this
person so much so that you're you want
to cheat on them then just you can you
can you can just call them on that you
can send a text message if you want to
you could little make you kind of a
scumbag but it's better than cheating
you could literally just send a text
message right before you're about to
cheat and just say hey that's not
working out working out or we're break
it up again you're still a jerk and a
scumbag if you do that but at least then
you're not technically cheating I mean
or or you could if you could control
yourself you could hold off for I don't
know 24 hours and just sit down with the
person and say listen this isn't working
I'm not into it
I strongly tempted to cheat on you and
so obviously this isn't happening
let's break up I if you could just hold
off on 24 you can't even do that you
your your so you have so little control
and so little concern for other people
including this person that you've been
with and you've probably claimed yet you
love and they at a minimum you've spent
time with and at a point you had some
affection for you have so little concern
for it for them and for their emotional
states like they're nothing they're just
garbage to you that you can't even hold
off for a few hours and just break it
off and then go do what you want to do
which I don't recommend that but it's at
least then you're not cheating and so
that's what makes it I just I don't get
it I don't get the cheat even though it
happens all the time in non marriage
relationships what's the just break up
you can there's nothing you have kids
you don't even uh it's nothing just
break up
so anyway okay and then she even says I
will we broke up a few days later okay
you couldn't waited so why do you do
that first
she says the friends eat okay then she
were over here she moves on and she's
describing one of her cheating
experiences this is what she's cheating
with a guy named drew on her boyfriend
Matt the frenzied grabbing and kissing
on Drew's bed that night for instance
didn't immediately reveal to me how
badly I needed to break up with Matt but
it did show me that my sexuality hadn't
dried up like I was worrying it had I
was still capable of feeling tingly and
wild over the coming weeks I noticed how
not there that feeling was with Matt how
it had really never really been there at
all it wasn't me that was broken it was
our relationship no it's you mainly it's
just you you're a terrible person and I
think it would have it would have taken
me so much longer to realize that if I
just walked out of Drew's room that
night was she saying that she couldn't
how could you possibly possibly realize
that her relationship with Matt wasn't
working if she didn't cheat on him
multiple times with some guy named drew
I mean most of us can figure these
things out without treating cheating on
our significant others with a guy named
drew or anyone else but she she couldn't
do it it said she had though so there's
no way she could have figured it out so
I don't really think cheating is a
capital
offense not when you're young and still
trying to learn how your heart and body
work I think about the way my
grandparents were in their 80s and still
happily married talked about their early
relationships and how much more
laid-back they were than then than any
of mine they talked about going on dates
and groups of people and attraction that
felt like popcorn in a hot pan quick and
random things were casual and open until
they were very serious that's not really
how people date anymore and so instead
some people cheat okay but your grandpa
they're saying they went on dates with
groups that doesn't mean that they were
having sex with all those people it just
means that they went on dates with
groups if people still do that it's a
normal thing to do I don't think your
grandparents were confessing to be pilot
to being polyamorous that's not the
point they were trying to make that she
goes into more details about the guys
that she slept with behind the backs of
guys she's dated and then she says this
is the part where I tell you that I
don't regret cheating
it also doesn't feel great though guilt
is like a gas in that it will expand to
fill whatever container it's in I felt
the pressure of it building inside me
and it was painful oh poor her poor poor
baby still regret and guilt or separate
feelings I know that given the chance I
wouldn't do any of this differently
because otherwise I'm not really sure
who I'd be now well you'd be a better
person rather than a dirtbag is what you
would be and then she comes to
conclusion which she arrives at after
cheating on another boyfriend with an
ex-boyfriend who she'd also cheated on
okay so now she's cheating on another
guy with the guy Matt from before
remember Matt well Matt's back of the
picture she's cheating on another guy
with Matt and she says I'd come a long
way since the night on Drew's bed when I
first cheated on that I learned so much
about myself in the years since then
like how it feels to be in love how a
kiss feels when I really wanted and how
sex feels would love and wanting it and
converge that third lesson is so rare to
learn and perfect when you experience it
how could I ever regret doing any of the
things I did to find it so there you go
here's a follow-up article that I'm just
predicting follow-up article in 20 years
the title is going to be I'm miserable
and alone and it's all men's fault
that's gonna be the follow-up article
because
but this this is someone you know if
this is your attitude you are going to
die alone I know you're young as well
I'm young you're not gonna be young
forever in fact you're gonna be yo if
you're in your 20s we by the time you're
in your 30s you're not you're still
young but you're not really it's you're
you're definitely like in grown-up
territory now you are you were in your
20s too but in your 30s you just you you
can't deny it anymore
so that's already almost gone for you it
sounds like and you're going to be old
or older for a lot longer than you were
young and so now you're just ensuring
that you're gonna be alone and miserable
and you're gonna die alone and no one is
gonna weep for you or care I mean that
not to be harsh about it but well yeah
I'm being harsh on purpose because
that's the reality when you live a
selfish narcissistic life and you never
learn how to commit yourself to anyone
you never learn how to have integrity or
fidelity or loyalty you're gonna be
alone you're gonna die and there's not
gonna be anyone around to care all your
friends are gonna be either dead or
they're gonna you know by then they're
all gonna have their own lives they're
gonna be worried about and that's what
you're setting yourself up for now
and I think that so that maybe the two
things that we take from this is that
you know she's approaching relationships
from this intensely selfish perspective
she's not the only one now this might be
an extreme example but I think that's
how most people approach relationships
actually these days even if they're not
serial cheaters but she's just taking
what is a common kind of philosophy for
human relationships these days and she's
just taking it to its logical extension
which again will lead all the way to her
dying alone but I think that a lot of so
she's although it she's taking the train
all the way there
a lot of people are on the same track
because how she keeps talking about this
is that I mean how made me feel and and
and how I feel and what I need i me i me
i me right I think
that's that's how people have been
raised and trained and and conditioned
to approach relationships does it make
you happy it's all about you there's no
element of service sacrifice the word
sacrifice we have pretty much completely
removed from religious discussions of
relationships or discussions of anything
and you just you you you cannot have a
healthy relationship of any kind with
anyone but especially a romantic
relationship and especially a marriage
if you're not willing to make sacrifices
for the other person it's simple it's as
simple as that all to also notice how
she treats guilt and shame as these
objectively bad things Oh
guilt and shame or to know guilt and
shame are good it the thing that
prompted the guilt and shame is not good
and that's why you have the guilt and
shame but the fact that you're feeling
it is good so guilt and shame is good in
the same way that the the sensation in
your finger from your nerve endings that
painful sensation when you touch a hot
stove is good the sensation is good
doesn't feel good but it is good because
it lets you know take your hand off the
stove you dummy
and that's another thing we that's a
distinction we fail to grasp these days
there is sometimes something can be good
even though it doesn't feel good and
sometimes something can be bad even
though it does feel good so those two
you know feeling good and being good are
not the same that guilty feeling is that
part is good because it's a it's you the
hey it is the it is the pain in your
finger letting you know that morally
speaking you have your hand on a hot
stove and it's time to pull it away all
right let's we're gonna get two emails
in a minute but first I want to tell you
about big token big token is a new app
that lets you share data about yourself
your interest your habits and then you
get paid for it
because right now you share a lot of
information already that you don't get
paid for
maybe well it's time that you take back
control that you make some money off of
your own information that's where big
token comes in here's how it works first
you download the app you sign up for a
free big token account I've done this
myself it's very easy only takes a
minute
next you complete actions to earn points
actions include answering surveys
checking into locations connecting your
social accounts and more then you can
redeem your points for rewards such as
cash gift cards you could donate to
charity I didn't choose that option just
to be honest with you but you can choose
it if you want to you choose the data
you share with big token and then you
get paid for it and you can also get
more points just by referring friends
and family your data is always secured
in big token you don't have to worry
about that there's a lot of problems
with data these days being misused and
abused well you don't have to worry
about it with big toga based on the data
you choose to share you'll be placed
into specific ad groups and brands will
buy access to those ad groups for use in
personalized advertising the best part
again you get paid if you want to start
earning money for your data go to the
App Store or Google Play search for big
token that's b.i.g Tok en that's one
word download the app sign up make sure
to use my referral code Matt Walsh again
search big token in the App Store or on
Google Play download the app use my
referral code matt walsh to sign up
claim your data and get paid with big
token alright
matt wall show at gmail.com is the email
address this is from Rodolfo says hi
Matt longtime listener since pride has
been the topic of the month I and I
agree with arguments from your fellow
daily wire contributors that pride is
the queen of all vices I came to over to
lose the realization that pride is what
keeps me from taking family handouts in
the form of money and the urge to get
ahead on my own my question is is this
form of pride bad as well and if so am i
confused with my reasoning for
preferring to do everything on my own
thanks love the show hope your recovery
is going well well I think thank you for
that well I am it's not going well I'm
in extreme pain at every moment and my
life is miserable I'm just kidding
actually it's going fine I I think that
we we have to stay
between a few things pride
confidence dignity three different
things so just because you're confident
doesn't mean that you're prideful
confidence is just recognizing abilities
that you have and realizing that they're
there that's what confidence is nothing
wrong with that that's good actually you
want to have that and just because you
have dignity doesn't mean that you're
private I think your desire to get ahead
on your own and your belief and not to
take handouts and your belief that you
can to me that seems like a combination
of dignity and confidence you're
confident you can do it you have you you
want you're dignified you want to be
able to stand on your own two feet as a
man that's dignity and so that's that's
what I would say now that can bleed into
pride if you're really in dire need and
you really need help and sometimes we
all need help and that's fine to reach
out if you're really in dire need and
and you still refuse help then yeah I
think it's prideful like extreme example
of you if you're drowning in the water
and a lifeguard is gonna come save you
and you say I don't know I got it and I
got it don't worry about it I got it and
then you just drowned well you literally
drowned from your pride your pride is
what sunk you there or a less extreme
example would be the stereotypical but
in my experience completely accurate
thing where the men a man is lost and
doesn't want to stop for directions
because he wants to figure out on his
own that's how I am even though it's so
cliched that's also pride so I think
that's how you sort through that this is
from QB says Matt I want to say
something regarding your argument in
this episode of your podcast I'm
referring to episode I did a few days
ago you say at 1804 that the border is
open in what universe is that true there
are thousands of border agents and
immigration officers there are hundreds
of miles of physical barrier I don't see
how making immigration even more illegal
will prevent
anyone from dying trying to get in
seriously the only reason this family
took the dangerous route they did was to
get a get around border security if the
US border were actually open as it
should be then this family would not
have died since they could have just
walked in through a safer path Matt you
sound like someone who wants to respond
to the black market and drugs by making
drugs even more illegal I know that you
understand that prohibition makes the
drug trade more dangerous why can't you
understand that for human movement would
you have responded to the existence of
the likes of Al Capone by making alcohol
more illegal well you're right if the
border was completely open and we had no
immigration laws of any kind and no we
weren't even attempting in any way to
enforce the border then yeah people
would be able to just walk right across
and probably fewer of them would die the
process the only problem is that they
would have no reason to even attempt it
in that case because in short order our
country would be just a failed state
like the countries to the south of us
the countries that those people are
fleeing from so this is really simple to
me right we have a border for the same
reason that you have a door on your
house and you have walls which comprise
your house if you didn't have walls you
didn't have a door you wouldn't have a
house it's the exact same concept
without a border we don't have a country
same concept in order to be a country we
need that we need there to be a
distinction between our country and the
ones surrounding it and we need to be
able to define and enforce that
distinction being a citizen has to mean
something it can't just be oh you happen
to walk across this line in the sand
because if it doesn't mean anything and
we just fling the doors open to everyone
then how long do you think we last as
America there's a reason why people want
to come here the reason is that we are
not those other countries if we become
those other countries then we are not in
any position to help the people from
those countries all right finally this
is from Katie says hi Matt I've recently
started listening to your show and I'm
really glad I found it what are your
thoughts
on the Pope changing the Lord's Prayer
I'm asking you specifically as a
Catholic who's supposed to follow the
Pope's interpretation of the Bible does
it bother you that he believes God
misspoke when telling the disciples his
prayer or is this something that should
have been changed from the start well
first of all I am NOT I'm not required
to follow the Pope's personal
interpretation of Bible passages I
disagree with many of his
interpretations in fact including on
issues such as capital punishment and
I'm perfectly entitled to do that and I
don't have to that's just because he
offers some opinion doesn't mean that
it's infallible and we all have to
follow it this particular change though
so they changed lead us not into
temptation and now it's gonna be do not
let us fall into temptation the idea
behind the change is that God would not
lead anyone into into temptation God is
not the tempter Satan is God doesn't try
to get us to sin so to pray that he
doesn't do that makes no sense because
you wouldn't do that anyway instead it
should be something like it'll prevent
us from succumbing to sin which is which
is what that means I'm okay with the
change honestly I'm not there plenty of
things this Pope does and when I first
heard this and I read the headline
months ago I had the reaction that
everyone else had which is uh what's
that what's that old rascal up to again
but then when I actually read what the
change is I'm fine with it because
people are saying like I guess you did
just there that he's changing God's Word
or changing Jesus's word he's not he's
changing the English translation to
better reflect the original meaning of
Jesus
people forget that we speak a different
language from what Jesus spoke so none
of our if you read in English then you
are not reading the literal words of
Jesus anyway you're reading a
translation and every translation is in
a sense in interpretation any
translation it's whether it's a
translation of the Bible or of crime and
punishment whatever it is you're you are
part of
translating is interpreting because it
can't just be a one-to-one like
literally just taking that word and
putting it on the paper in sequential
order because then it's not gonna make
any sense so you have to rearrange the
words a little bit you have to use
sometimes different words to bring out
the meaning of the original in English
in a way that's gonna make sense to us I
mean the King James Bible all of the
formal flowers that's not in the
original especially that's not how these
that's not at least people spoke that's
an interpretation trying to bring out
the deeper sort of meaning of the
original so I think that that's what
this is it's just it's not changing it
it's just the argument and maybe you
disagree but just to be clear the
argument here is no we're not changing
with Jesus we're not saying Jesus
misspoke we're saying that our English
translation for these many years has
been wrong and has not totally captured
what Jesus was actually trying to say
cuz he wasn't saying that God would ever
lead us into temptation that's not the
point
so that's the argument so so again if
you disagree with it that it's just it's
a disagreement of oh no I think that the
translation was accurate before it's not
an argument of should we change Jesus's
words or not because no one is saying
that we should in this case all right um
that's it I think we'll leave it there
have a great weekend everybody
Godspeed today on the Ben Shapiro show
we recap night two of the Democratic
debates all the excitement's all the
splendor all the misery that's today on
the bench puro show